[Music]
We're no strangers to love.
You know the rules and so do I.
No commitments from what I'm thinking
of.
You wouldn't get this from any other
guy. I just want to tell you how I'm
feeling.
It's going to make you understand. Never
going to give you up. Never going to let
you down. Never going to run around and
desert you. Never going to meet you.
Never going to say goodbye.
a lie and hurt you.
We've known each other for so long.
Your heart's been aching, but you're too
shy to say it. We don't know what's been
going on.
We know the game and we're going to play
it.
[Music]
If you ask me how I'm feeling,
don't tell me you're too
[Music]
let you down. Never run around and
desert you.
You never say goodbye.
[Music]
and hurt you. I will give you
let you down. I will run around and
desert you.
You will see
[Music]
you.
Never going to give. Never going to give
>> Never going to give. Never going to give
you.
>> We've known each other for so long.
Your heart's been aching, but you're too
shy to say it. We both know what's been
going on.
We know the game and we're going to play
it. I just want to tell you how I'm
feeling.
Got to make you understand.
[Music]
Heat. Heat. Heat.
you will run around and desert you. I
will you will say goodbye
and hurt you. I'm going to give you I'm
going to let you down. I'm going to run
around and desert you. I'm going to make
you cry. I'm going to say goodbye.